wasps they're pretty annoying but what
would happen if all the wasps in the
world just disappeared
well before you start celebrating let's
have a little look at some of the
lesser-known wonders of wasps if there
are no wasps it's not just the insect
that would be lost but a complex society
with some surprising similarities to our
own all wasps have a role to fulfill be
it as a queen or the wasp equivalent of
a caretaker a guard or even a nanny
they're also a lot smarter than we give
them credit for some wasps can recognize
each other's faces so they know where
they are in the hierarchy and if they're
Friend or Foe
and they can be trained to detect
explosives and illegal drugs wasps are a
key predator and the loss of any
predator would have a huge knock-on
effect on the ecosystem this is because
wasps protect plant life crops and other
creatures from spiders millipedes flies
caterpillar is a fedora
in fact they catch around 14 million
kilograms worth of insects every year in
the UK alone most of which they take
home to feed their young
so without wasps you'd see many plants
left unprotected and a big rise in the
number of uninvited creatures in your
home the bee population has gone down
significantly over the past 30 years
because of pesticides changes in land
use and climate change
wasps face a similar threat they just
don't capture the public imagination in
the same way studies show people
associate bees with more positive cuddly
imagery like honey flowers and pollen
while wasps evoke more negative terms
like stinging pain and rage but this is
unfair because wasps perform many of the
same fractions as bees and wasps are
crucial pollinators too in fact if wasps
didn't exist we'd lose over 100
different types of orchids and figs too
that might not sound like a big deal but
every species of fig relies on its own
species of pollinating fig wasp for
fertilization in turn more than a
thousand tropical birds and mammals
depend on figs and therefore wasps to
survive there are thousands of species
of wasp sight
most of which go about their business
quietly and only 1% of these are the
type that buzz around your picnic the
most off-putting feature of the wasp is
its ability to sting but that sting has
some interesting features it contains a
toxin which lab studies suggest could
have anti-cancer properties
so wasps have a lot to offer by the time
they're out and after your eye screen
they're in the last throes of their life
which is only two weeks to a month long
because when the Queen has no more need
for them they have to leave confused
jobless homeless and desperate for a
sugar fix so let's give the wasps a
break after all without them we'd have
more pests less biodiversity and a more
global food insecurity so as much as
it's our instinct to panic and flap our
arms whenever we see them don't stop and
watch them and see just how amazing
these disliked and wildly
underappreciated insects actually are
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon